introduce you the first speaker of the
boot camp
uh manchester united it's really great
pleasure to
have him speak to us as many of you know
monty
has made numerous profound and long
lasting contributions
to theoretical evolutionary biology
and we are and he's actually a role
model to many of us including myself
and we are really lucky to have him tell
us about the historical development of
evolutionary biology
thank you it's a it's a pleasure to be
here and a pleasure
to be asked to give the opening lectures
i will say
first of all i'm trained as a
mathematician i'm
i've worked in evolutionary biology for
a long time but i've never actually
studied evolutionary biology
so but i have taught evolution for
non-majors
many times and what i will what i will
cover in my first lecture is
the history of darwinism through
neo-darwinism
and the later developments
and then in the section second lecture
i'll talk specifically about the history
of population genetics
not the theory of population genetics
which steve evans and his
and others will we'll discuss later
today
but focusing largely on empirical
studies in population genetics
now to to begin uh any proper discussion
of evolution begins with this book the
origin of species
by charles darwin published in 1859 the
main reason i put this title page
is to make sure you know what the title
is it is on the origin of species it is
not as many people
think mistakenly on the origin of these
species
it's not about the evolution of humans
it's about
evolution now
when it was published in 1859 this book
created a scientific revolution on a par
with the copernican revolution
of astronomy or the germ theory of
disease
it had a profound effect on thinking in
the latter part of the 19th century
it was very controversial and to some
extent still is very controversial
nevertheless even people who argue
vigorously about it aren't entirely
clear
sometimes on what actually darwin's
theory of evolution is
and so i will follow steve gould in
distinguishing three parts
of what's in the origin first of all
there is the fact of evolution
that is evolution occurred when he
darwin didn't call it that
he called it descent with modification
but it means the same thing that is
species evolved from
something else and
darwin emphasized that there were
probably there was probably one or only
a few common ancestors
and from these few common ancestors or
one
the diversity of life evolved
somehow that's the fact of evolution
that evolution occurred
the second part of darwin's theory is
that he proposed a specific
pattern of evolution not only did
evolution occur
but it occurred in a specific way it
occurred
slowly gradually and so
slowly that it was imperceptible
when viewing living things at any one
time from a human perspective
so even though evolution occurred you
don't see it occurring
he had to after all account for that
fact we don't see species
changing every day or at least we people
didn't think so until they looked very
closely
so there's a pattern of evolution you
could believe the fact of evolution
but not darwin's pattern you could for
example think that
instead of gradual evolution there was
what
people did and still call saltational
evolution
where there was no change or very slow
change and then suddenly
in at once a species changed into
something else
but logically that's a distinct pattern
even though you accept the pattern of
evolution even though you accept the
fact of evolution
finally darwin proposed a mechanism
evolution
of evolution namely that evolution
occurred by
by the continued action of natural
selection
and natural selection acted
on heritable variation that was present
in all species
so some of the differences between
individuals affected their survival
and reproduction those differences were
inherited
and inevitably natural selection would
result in a change in the species
composition
his focus was not on the individual his
focus was on the population
or the species he didn't always make
that distinction
um once again you could accept the fact
of evolution
you could accept the pattern of
evolution but you could
reject natural selection
which people generally don't do or you
could
question the sufficiency of natural
selection
when darwin proposed natural selection i
think most people who viewed it thought
that was obvious it was something that
because he built
on what people knew about the selection
acting artificial selection performed on
domesticated plants and animals
he simply generalized it in the same way
that newton generalized the force of
gravitation
on earth to account for the celestial
movements of the
sun and the moon he generalized
the action of artificial selection to
create
long-term changes and many thomas huxley
for example
said when he after he read the book how
extremely stupid of me not to have
thought of that
it's an obvious idea so i don't think
many people questioned whether natural
selection
could work whether it could cause
evolution to occur
but it's a different question to say
natural selection is the only mechanism
causing evolution to occur darwin was
very
very clear in saying that that natural
selection was
sufficient it was the only thing causing
change
now darwin's pattern but these of course
these ideas were not independent and
darwin did not
present them as independent ideas
before people would accept the fact of
evolution he had to have a plausible
mechanism
and there darwin was also
clear if if change is slow and gradual
and continuous
and if natural selection accounted for
all change
a necessary consequence is that at every
point
at every time change occurred because
there was an
immediate improvement by natural by the
action of natural selection
so when you have a transition between
major forms
for example transition from non-flying
animals to flying animals or from
swimming animals to
land-based walking animals what we
regard as major transitions that we know
had to have occurred because we have
both non-flying and
flying organisms we have both swimming
and walking organisms and so on
every intermediate step had to be an
improvement
natural selection had to be acting at
every time
to cause the change to
cause swimming organisms
to continually improve and become
land-based organisms so that's a
consequence of
of that and darwin was very clear in in
the origin saying if it could be proved
that a transition occurred in spite of
the action of natural selection
so that the intermediate forms were less
well adapted
than the ancestral forms then that would
disprove his theory
and he was very clear in the origin
about having the fact of evolution
and the spec separate creation of
species as
alternative hypotheses that he
continually tested much of the origin as
a long argument
for evolution versus
what we what we would call creationism
separate creation
of species that then no longer change
now darwin was by no means the first
person to propose
that evolution occurred many many people
discussed it
uh in various forms and lamarck more
than 50 years before
proposed a fairly complete theory of
evolution
he his theory said evolution occurred
that organisms the pattern of evolution
was not as complete as darwin's but he
proposed that
species increased in their degree of
perfection
and furthermore that there was an
internal striving for perfection
and those individuals that were most
successful in striving
transmitted the changes that occurred
during their lifetime to their offspring
something we now call the inheritance of
inquiry of acquired characters
or lamarckian evolution there were lots
of evolutionary theories before darwin
darwin's book was most was
uniquely successful though because at
first it was very convincing
he amassed a large amount of evidence he
presented
it in a very persuasive way and it was a
very complete theory
he didn't ignore all the facts he
covered the geological record the
geographic distribution of species
he dealt with what he saw as potential
objections to the theory of his theory
of evolution
and so on so it was a very convincing
case you couldn't just dismiss it
without
taking on a body of evidence that he
amassed
and dismissed that or parts of that
nevertheless it wasn't and when it was
proposed suddenly
evolutionary thinking was was part of
the intellectual universe
this figure is the only figure from the
origin and it illustrates the gradual
pattern and darwin's
darwin's view of of evolution
there are no saltational changes that is
there are no jumps
here that then lead to a a new group
he was quite clear that some some
organisms didn't
change very much they didn't leave any
ancestors
others left very few and others left
many he was also very clear that
extinction was an important part of the
process
now after the origin was published it
was the
evolutionary ideas were discussed in
great at great length
and there were several serious
challenges i mean there were other
other challenges that were based on
simply it can't be true
bishop wilberforce's wife is reported to
have said
i hope it's not true and if it is true i
hope it doesn't become generally known
um but there were serious serious
challenges by
by very reputable people that had to be
taken seriously and which did influence
darwin's thinking
and did influence the development of
evolutionary biology
the first one of the first came from
william thompson later lord
kelvin very eminent uh physicist
and founder of one of the developers of
the theory of thermodynamics
and part of but darwin part of darwin's
theory is that there was essentially
unlimited time available for evolution
to occur
so extremely slow processes could work
for a long time producing the diversity
of life we see today
and he he got this view from lyell a
geologist who who
proposed it earlier in the 19th century
uh thompson said no this can't be true
there isn't
an unlimited amount of time because the
sun
would cool the sun would collapse
according to the accepted model of the
sun
and the earth would cool it started out
very hot
but the laws of thermodynamics allowed
him to calculate
the number of years and the estimates
varied from 20 million to 400 million
and he refined it this argument
consistent went on for a long time
and this was i mean 400 million years is
a long time
but it wasn't unlimited amounts of time
and this bothered darwin and this
bothered many of his supporters
and it caused i mean huxley's response
was
well if we only have 400 million years
then that's how long evolution takes
probably there were saltational changes
in addition to gradual changes
and that i mean it was all very hazy
darwin himself never
relented and many of the geologists
never relented they said no we think we
have more time
but they they didn't try to argue
it wasn't resolved until the discovery
of radioactivity
which slowed the cooling of the earth
and the thermonuclear reactions in the
sun which
changed the dynamics of the sun from the
the model thompson
used second serious challenge to the
theory came
from mathematicians and the most notable
was a
an eminent engineer named fleming jenkin
who
argued that natural selection wouldn't
work
and his argument was very simple he said
look if you
have a new type in a population that
appears
then the process of blending inheritance
would cause that type to be blended in
and so you wouldn't per the the new
advantageous type would not persist in
the population
now we know about mentalism we know that
argument isn't
valid but this bothered darwin greatly
and in later editions of the origin
he reverted to a more lamarchian mode of
inheritance
he called it the effect of habit
and so where where in the in the first
edition of the origin it was just
straight inheritance
there was no inheritance of acquired
characters
later editions allowed for the
inheritance of acquired characters
because he needed that to prevent
variation from disappearing
the third argument was more subtle and
more important to us
it was it in darwin anticipated this
third objection and darwin anticipated
this when he discussed what he called
organs of extreme perfection
and he used the argument of the eye
and he said and in some detail although
the eye is this marvelously complex
structure that was used by many people
to argue for the perfection of creation
by a creator darwin said no it through a
series of improvements
that's the important thing every step
was an improvement you can go from the
early
photoreceptors to various
intermediate stages each of which
represented improvement a structural
improvement
on the visual system which
led to the evolution of the modern eye
so he said all you need to do
is is think about it sufficiently
and if you were lucky you will find
intermediates in nature
which tell you that these intermediate
stages existed
so there are are species that simply
have crude photoreceptors
and there are species which have
photoreceptors with some degree of
physical protection and so on
now this argument works and darwin
thought darwin liked the argument a lot
the trouble is it depends on intuition
and it depends on
intermediate forms that you think
existed
that you think were improvements on
previous forms
that may not exist today and
it may not be convincing to other people
your intuition may not be convincing to
other people
wikipedia um
but there you yeah there are lots around
this is a standard introductory biology
discussion of the eye and it but it does
follow
darwin's verbal discussion the trouble
is when you have
for example the evolution of flight
evolution you you think well you have
powered flight with a
general lift generated by muscles
you can envision an intermediate stage
where you have gliding
but you may feel that the initial stages
of gliding
um may not be a functional improvement
and other people may feel it is but it's
now it's a question of
intuition again with gliding you can
find flying squirrels and other or
other animals and insects that
look like they might be plausible
intermediates
but it depends on intuition you don't
often have
for example the the gliding insects
proto wings in insects and insect
fossils don't look like they're good for
gliding
and in fact maybe coal in in integrative
biology has argued that actually they
were
used for heat regulation and not gliding
and only later served the
purpose of flight the trouble is for
every
major transition you owe you have this
logical problem
and this is this has caused some people
this caused people
at the time and still caused some people
today to argue about this to
sufficiency of natural selection yes we
know natural selection works
most of the time but is it all the
change attributable to natural selection
is there or is there something else that
can carry you
between one adapted well adapted form
and another well adapted
form where the intermediates are not
well adapted
does that never happen it's very
difficult to
prove the negative to say oh that never
happens
darwin said it never happens
but people have their favorite
characters their favorite species
and they often have trouble envisioning
the
the the inter functioning intermediates
and then as i will explain later there
are
mechanisms which cause us to think that
maybe the
these steps can be taken in the uh
without the action of natural selection
so this this is a continuing discussion
in
evolutionary biology okay now we move
forward to
1900 and the real uh the rediscovery of
mendelism
and by three people hugo de vries shown
here and then chermak and koreans
roughly simultaneously and roughly
independently
rediscovered mendel's laws of
inheritance
and this of course led to the the
development of the field of genetics
from our point of view devries is by far
the most important
because he does he not only rediscovered
mendel's laws
but he did he just rediscovered them in
a species called the evening primrose
shown here and his mendelian traits not
just
were single gene modifications going
from wrinkled peas to round peas or
tall plants to short plants the kind of
mendel studied
his mutations were what he called macro
mutations
they several traits at once
were inherited in a mendelian fashion
and this uh this is just one example i
found on the web but there are many many
mutants that devries studied which
caused one type of plant
to become something very different
another variety of plant
and so he said not only is this this
mentalism
this is an important mechanic mechanism
of evolution
because these macro mutations solve the
problem of major transitions
we don't need to have infinitesimally
slow changes
each one being an improvement instead we
can go in one step from this to this
and not worry about having
functionally worse intermediate forms
because the intermediate forms didn't
exist
so devries proposed a mechanism
namely macromutation which is in
addition
to selection acting on small variation
and he proposed a pattern that some of
the major transitions
occurred because they were saltational
they were major changes from one form to
another
allowed by this new mechanism
macromutation
this is only the first in a long series
a century-long series
of genetic discoveries that have been
proposed as additions to
natural selection transposons meiotic
drive all these other things
one of the first the first papers on
each of these
said this is in addition to darwin and
devries for many years
was regarded as the most important
evolutionary biologist of his age
now it after about 1910 he stopped being
so important because it was discovered
that his macro mutations
were the result of ring chromosomes
so they weren't single mendelian loci
they were
chromosomal groups inherited together
in a complex way that doesn't occur in
most species
it seems to be it's not unique to
evening primroses but it's
it's very restricted so he couldn't
generalize and p
other people couldn't generalize from
that
now one after the rediscovery of
mentalism
the in the mentalism the inheritance of
mendelian genes was not immediately
accepted as the universal basis for
inheritance
many people there was a group of people
in the uh
at the end of the 19th century galton
pearson
weldon and others who formed what they
called the biometrical school of
inheritance and they invented
statistical rules
to describe inheritance galton
discovered regression
he first used regression in this context
and they had he had a fairly complete
statistical theory
of inheritance and the biometricians in
particular said well look there are yes
they're definitely mendelian genes
but mendelian genes are not really the
stuff of evolution
they are unusual that real
inheritance and real evolution is of
continuously varying
characters and this is one of many such
pictures where you have the
a distribution of heights of males and
females
in a group of humans i guess i can't
quite read the uh
t-shirt yukon okay
it's anyway some you know obviously some
genetics introductory genetics class was
marched out onto the football field for
this purpose
um so continuously varying characters
were the real stuff of evolution and
mendelian genes weren't a part of that
there were two different kinds of
inheritance
now in 1908 an important year for
population genetics
uh schul proposed what is called the
multifactorial theory
he said in effect yes the uh
there appears to be continuous traits
but really they're made up of different
groups different genotypes and each
genotype is made up of several mendelian
loci and so he
this is this is uh shul's statement of
the multi-factorial theory and then
lynch and walsh
walsh in an important textbook on
quantitative genetics
explained it in modern terms
and so this and so the biometricians and
the mendelians argued for a long time
and they were arguing of course about
the basis of genetics but they were also
arguing about the genetic basis of
evolution
were there two kinds of inheritance or
only one
and gradually the the multifactorial
theory gained ground
and was finally resolved with a
paper by fisher in 1918 i'll say a
little bit more about
um but the biometrical
theory school evolved quickly
into what we call the subject of
quantitative genetics which still deals
largely with statistical ideas
regression analysis of variants
using the basic tools of biometry but
now giving them a genetic interpretation
now also in 1918 or 1908
there was an important paper published
by g h hardy very eminent
mathematician in england i had i
couldn't resist quoting the in
the introduction of the paper i'm
reluctant to intrude in a discussion
concerning matters of which i have no
expert knowledge would only more people
have that modesty
and he also says i expected everybody to
know this
but uh punnett in particular he used to
play cricket with punnett
and punnett apparently believed that
dominant genes would increase in
frequency just by virtue of their being
dominant
and so hardy proved what we know as the
hardy
uh weinberg result that no
mendelian inheritance will preserve very
variability
on its own the random may what we call
random mating
will not result in the loss of genetic
variability as flaming jenkins and other
others had uh had claimed so
mentalism does resolve this but only
with hardy
and weinberg was a german physician who
derived the same result
independently
so after the uh
well the the biometricians and the
biometricians basically never gave up
but they did die
and at about the same time r.a fisher
published a famous and famously
difficult paper which reconciles
biometry and mendelism by showing that
all the rules of biometry
regression in particular
and the regression involving different
classes of relatives
all could be derived from mendelism
um and so this this
this paper had a profound effect on the
development of genetics
because it really eliminated the claim
that there had to be two different
classes of
inheritance really only one class of
inheritance
but many characters were multifactorial
and that's why they didn't follow
mendel's simple
simple laws okay after the uh
after the after 1918 population genetics
developed fairly slowly only a few
people
um were doing
doing much work but the ones who were
doing it were rather good
fisher sewell wright jbs haldane
the few others developed what we call
what we think of as the foundations of
population genetics
now steve evans and others will talk
about this in some detail but i want to
mention just how it fits into the
picture of
of darwinism and neo-darwinism
in the 1920s haldane
and fisher spent some time
showing that natural selection acting on
mendelian variants
could account for slow and gradual
evolution
what haldane specifically showed is that
if you consider evolution as a change in
allele frequencies
this was a new view where you went from
change in phenotype that darwin
considered
to a change in allele frequencies that
selection acting on very small
differences
in average survivorship associated with
some allele
could produce a complete substitution of
one allele
allelic type for another in a relatively
short time a few hundred or a few
thousand
generations now this is something that's
obvious to all of us today you think
well what was the big deal
well the big deal was that this showed
that
mendelian inheritance wasn't completely
consistent with darwin's theory of
evolution
even if the effect of natural selection
was very weak that is if the differences
created by different genotypes were too
small to be obvious to us
so that most people weren't most
organisms weren't dying because they had
bad genotypes
natural selection could still produce
changes on in a few hundred or few
thousand generations
much more rapidly than the changes that
were observed in the fossil record
so there's no incompatibility between
between darwinism darwin's theory of
natural selection
and mendel's theory of inheritance so
and in the 1920s mendalism
was incorporated into evolutionary
biology
and it led to what we what we what i'm
what i have been calling neo-darwinism
or what is sometimes called the modern
synthesis
now the next one the next step in this
is
fisher's book in 1930 called the
genetical theory of natural selection
and fisher proved what he modestly
called the fundamental theorem of
natural selection
and this theorem this is has been
treated with almost talmudic reverence
people still write elaborate papers
explaining exactly what
fisher meant and people argue vigorously
about exactly what he meant
um roughly speaking what the fundamental
theorem says though
is that natural selection tends to
improve a species the
the mean fitness tends to increase
and by the way if you have strong
feelings about the fundamental theorem i
don't want to hear about them
so but this confirmed this was the
culmination of the kind of work that
haldine in particular began and fischer
to some extent
began showing that not only what could
natural selection change allele
frequencies
but it changed it overall in the way
that darwin
described that his species tended to
improve
and so the fisherian view of evolution
by natural selection
was that very large populations were
evolving
under the action of natural selection
tending to improve them step by step by
step by step
exactly as darwin described in his book
now the alternative view and alternative
view
was introduced by sewell wright so
wright wrote a paper it's published in
1931
and he summarized his view of evolution
now wright
emphasized the role of genetic drift he
emphasized the randomness
of the transmission of mendelian alleles
especially in small populations and he
and fisher developed the theory of
genetic drift in the 1920s
wright did so using path coefficients
fischer introduced a diffusion equation
that was almost right uh
komogorov forward equation so the theory
of genetic drift was developed and this
is
this is right presentation of a lot of
what is now
absolutely standard population genetics
theory which i won't review
but we also introduced
a metaphor for evolution this was
actually from a 1932 paper where he was
asked to
present a simple summary of his theory
for
congress in genetics held that year and
his view was very different from fishers
and darwin's he said well there are
local optimum
optima in
average fitness and
these local optima were separated by
areas for which the average fitness was
lower he called these adaptive peaks
and these adaptive valleys and this is a
very powerful metaphor that people
use all the time in evolutionary biology
and but it assumes what darwin
said was not true namely that well that
there were
it assumes that there are combinations
of traits
that go from
that are less well adapted separating
combinations that are
better adapted
and furthermore genetic drift was a
mechanism to take you from one to the
other from one adaptive peak to the
other
and he skept this as a hand sketch of
his where he shows that in a large
population
you will simply go to the nearest local
maximum
but if genetic drift is allowed to work
it can take you from one maximum
and carry you to another he emphasized
that this was more likely to happen
in subdivided populations where you have
lots of local populations that could
then
send new well-adapted combinations to
other populations that's what this is
trying to represent
he called this the shifting balance
theory
this is another mechanism that's
proposed in addition to darwin to
darwin natural selection to take you
from one well-adapted suite of
characters to another that is to cross
an adaptive valley
now the dispute between darwin and
between wright and fisher was never
really resolved
but by 1940 when this book was published
the modern synthesis by julian huxley
one of the descendants of thomas huxley
there was an established theory
summarized by this and often it was
called the modern synthesis after this
book
that is and it was darwinism plus
mentalism
the pa of course in fact nobody doubted
the fact of evolution
the pattern of evolution was gradual but
the presentation of the pattern wasn't
as dogmatic
as darwin the rates rates of evolution
varied and
a paleontologist studied in some detail
variation in rates of evolution
natural selection was predominant but
because of rights efforts
there was room for the effect of genetic
drift
how much room depended on who was
reading
or who was explaining it of course when
wright explained it there was a lot of
room when fisher explained that there
was no room whatsoever
so i think people like huxley who who's
not a
a geneticist or mathematician uh just
said well you know you guys work it out
and i'll
you know i will try you will be trying
to be inclusive
um
okay so the the and the punctuated of
the the neo-darwinian theory
became the predominant theory the
textbook standard
for many years
and really the
the most the most important challenge to
it was by stephen jay gould and niles
eldridge
in a starting a paper first published in
1972
and presenting a view of evolution which
they called the punctuated equilibrium
theory
and roughly speaking and this is
this is an area where people will still
argue
about it roughly speaking they they
contrasted darwin's pattern of evolution
a gradual
what they called phyletic gradualism
but it's the same as darwin's gradual
theory and that and fischer's
gradual theory and they said well now
when you look in the fossil record in
detail
as the fossil record got better and
better and better
i should mention when darwin talked
about the fossil record he
for the most part didn't present
detailed evidence of a gradual theory
a gradual pattern of evolution what he
the the title the chapter on the fossil
record is
is imperfections in the fossil record
that is if you have a fossil here and a
fossil here
the fossil here you can't tell whether
it's gradual or not
but what gould and eldridge said is when
you get more and more
fossils you start to fill in a pattern
that looks more like this
that there's the state what they said
was the stasis
of widespread species and when new
species appear in the fossil record they
you see a lot of morphological change
associated with the
appearance of a new species so the
punctuated equilibrium theory was a
theory about a generalization about the
pattern of evolution
now many people also said
and other people were somewhat ambiguous
on the question of whether this
implied there were additional mechanisms
to cause the punctuated
equilibrium pattern and some people said
well
yes this this looks sudden from the
point of the view of the fossil record
but this could be 50 or 100
000 years plenty of time for mass
selection to act
it's not at all incompatible with
neo-darwinian mechanisms
other people this was when transposons
had been just discovered and they were
known to be powerful mutagens in
drosophila
other people said well no but this opens
the door for additional mechanisms
this pattern at least some of the time
might actually reflect
reflect saltational change and people
argue about this vigorously
uh my impression is that the argument
over the mechanisms have disappeared as
if people as people have found uh
these other transposons and other
genetic mechanisms not to be as powerful
agents of change as they thought they
might be
and and but paleontologists debate about
whether the punctuated equilibrium
pattern
uh reflects the history of
different groups and to what extent it
reflects the history
okay well that's all i'm going to say
about the the general theory of
evolution and as i say next
in a few minutes whenever i'm supposed
to start i'll take up more explicit
discussions of
population genetics thank you